ça lui est ce que vous savez pourquoi le
docteur oumou s'appelle le docteur ou
alors que dans la série jamais personne
l'appelle le docteur roux la série a été
créée en 1963 donc bien avant ce que
pensent la plupart des gens ça a
cartonné jusqu'en 1996 et après ça a été
repris à partir de 2005 il ya eu plus de
800 épisode une douzaine d'acteurs qui
ont interprété le docteur le docteur le
docteur qui s'appelle dans la série le
docteur il n'y a pas d'autre nom que le
docteur au départ ce qui était prévu
dans la série ce qui s'appelle le doctor
who et que tout le monde l'appelle le
docteur roux puisque personne ne savait
vraiment qu'ils s'étaient c'était ça
l'idée de départ de cécile edwin bébert
le scénariste donc l'idéal a été mise de
côté mais ils en font un clin d'oeil
dans la série bon déjà parce que ça a
donné le titre de la série mais si vous
regardez la série en vo vous verrez
qu'ils sont fait un petit trip puisqu'à
chaque fois que le docteur se présente
il dit je suis le docteur et la personne
en face répond docteur qui skie en
anglais donne
vous avez compris comme prévu cet été y
ait une vidéo tous les deux jours sur un
truc un petit peu léger histoire de
s'amuser cet été donc ce sera jusqu'au
30 août alors rendez vous après demain
penser à liker la vidéo abonnez-vous si
ce n'est pas déjà fait ciao